[Music]
I'm Alexander bricken I'm on the applied
AI team at anthropic so I work very
closely with customers to do technical
implementation work and I also bring
that advice back to product research and
model research um I'm going to pass it
over to Joe hey everyone it's great to
be here my name is Joe Bailey I work on
the go to market team at anthropic I
joined anthropic over a year ago now so
I've seen our models evolve from a 2.1
to today's capabilities and I think
day-to-day what's really exciting is
we're working with AI leaders who are
solving real business problems um that
just seemed impossible a year ago so
really excited about how quickly
everything is
moving okay for today we will do um a
quick overview uh you know who we are
our mission and then we'll focus a lot
on implementing Ai and best practices
and common mistakes uh Alex and I
actually didn't just take this from our
own experience but we uh talked to a
number of our colleagues so this is all
based on hundreds and hundreds of
customer interactions um so we hope
there's some actionable insights to take
out of
this awesome so what is anthropic so we
are an AI safety and research company
building the world's best and safest uh
large language models we were founded a
few years ago by some of the leading
experts in Ai and since our Inception
we've not only released uh multiple
iterations of our Frontier models we've
done so by being at the bleeding edge of
safety techniques of research and
policy I'm going to pass it over to Alex
to talk a little B about our Marquee
model awesome and so some of you are
probably familiar but the most recent
model we launched was Sonet 3.5 new uh
in late October of last year
um you might be familiar with it because
if you're a developer uh Sonet is
actually one of the leading models in
the code space so if you're familiar
with evaluations like sbench which is an
agentic coding eval uh Sona is still at
the top of the leaderboard for that um I
won't go too much into the details on
the eval side so let's keep
moving um so yeah in addition to what
Joe mentioned we have a lot of different
research directions that we're focused
on um and these are really distributed
but have overlap between you know model
capabilities product research and AI
safety the one that differentiates us I
would say is the interpretability and
this realistically is reverse
engineering the models and trying to
figure out actually how they're thinking
and maybe why they're thinking and then
an additional capability in terms of
steering them in the right direction
depending on a use case so let's dive
into that a little bit more we're still
very early in interpretability research
it's worth mentioning as you can see
there's kind of like a longer timeline
and we're really only at the the first
half half of that maybe even the first
25% um but we're we're really
approaching it in these stages that
build upon each other so these include
things like understanding so grasping AI
decision-making detection so actually
being able to understand specific
behaviors and put labels on those
steering so influencing the AI input in
some some way shape or form and I'll get
to an example of that in a second and
then finally explainability and that's
really where you unlock business value
associated with interpretability methods
and so while we see interpretability in
the long term providing you know a lot
of significant improvements in AI safety
reliability and usability specifically
our interpretability team uses methods
to understand feature activations at the
model level and then has published
research on these uh in towards Mon
semanticity and scaling mon semanticity
which are two papers I highly recommend
um and then as the technology improves
into kind of detection landscapes for
example you can imagine having a much
better grasp at uh the actual thinking
and behavior of the model or even
discovering sleeper agents for safety
reasons that might be buried deep within
uh model capabilities so a good example
of that is imagine you ask the model
what were the scores of the NBA matches
today right and let's say it knows the
answer and it says how Steph Curry you
know scored 30 points this would lead to
a feature activation of for example
feature number 304 famous NBA players
realistically that's a group of neurons
activating an recognizable pattern that
we've identified across all mentions of
famous basketball players when model is
answering a question not just Steph
Curry um and you also might have heard
of Golden Gate Claude that was an
example of us steering the model uh
basically amping up the activation in
the Golden Gate Direction and thus
whenever you'd ask a question like what
should I paint my bedroom Claude would
respond oh you should paint it red like
the Golden Gate Bridge and maybe it
should have some like you know pillars
in it or something
I'm going to pass over to Joe to talk a
little bit about some of the customers
we work with yeah so I'm going to frame
this in two ways one is uh sort of early
on discussions and the other would be
just examples of customers that are
doing really cool things so in
conversations there's obviously a lot of
noise and Buzz and everything and that's
fantastic but we often encourage our
customers uh to sort of get back to the
basics and how can they use AI to solve
uh the core problem that your product is
trying to solve we also get to work with
ton of uh of AI native or AI startups
and this is how they're thinking about
their product and I think you want to
move Beyond uh chatbots and
summarization these can be great options
but I'd be thinking more like where do
you want to place bigger bets and to
give an example um if you just click one
more time fancy slide uh imagine you're
an onboarding and upskilling platform
the problem that you solve for customers
is you help them get ramp really quickly
and then you help them get to the next
phase of their career by equipping them
with skills so for instance you might be
public speaking you want to get good at
or you might want to become a manager
and so it would be easy to say okay
let's summarize course content or let's
um uh let's have a Q&A chat bot that
answers questions along the way and they
could be helpful but I would actually
think about it differently so what about
if you could hyper personalize uh course
content based on each indiv individual
employees context or if someone is like
breezing through all the course content
could you adapt it dynamically to make
it more challenging uh so they're
actually getting more value out of it
and then the last one that I
particularly like would be what if you
could uh dynamically update uh course
material based on people learning about
the customer so if someone was a visual
learner great let's make visual content
for them and having the AI having the ml
sorry the the large language model just
do that automatically and you have to
think does that solve the problem more
than summarization or or a Q&A chatbot
um so really good food for thought
and to sort of talk about some of the
customers uh that we see achieving
really industry-leading results by
combining their own domain expertise and
our um our model so I won't read off
each but just a couple of call outs one
is uh AI impacting different Industries
we have uh taxes we have legal we have
uh project management they're using AI
to uh drastically enhance their customer
experience they make it more uh like
easier to use they make it more Trust
worthy um and so it's really improving
the experience versus just being like a
nice to have and then they're achieving
a real a real high quality um of output
right you can't be giving you can't be
hallucinating when you're doing your
taxes uh could just you know that could
lead to all sorts of things so we're
thrilled that they're seeing these these
sort of like business critical workflows
powered by AI driving really positive
outcomes for them and also their
customers awesome I can do this one yeah
so um getting started I just quickly uh
there's two two key points here so if
you go to the next slide um what are our
products we have our API we have Claude
for work our API uh is for businesses
that want to embed AI in their product
and services and then Claud for work
empowers your entire organization to
take advantage of AI in the day-to-day
work we also have uh next one we also
have a partnership with AWS and gcp and
you can kind of get the best of both
worlds here you can access our Frontier
models on Bedrock or in vertex you can
deploy these applications in your
existing environment um and you but you
and so you don't have to manage any new
infrastructure so it really sort of
breaks down like any barriers to entry
so you're getting the best of both W
tier we talk a little bit about support
throughout this talk it to us it doesn't
matter if you're accessing us through a
third party or our first party so I just
wanted to call that
out awesome so now that we've talked a
little bit about some of the customers
how do we actually set set customers up
for Success when working with them at
anthropic so just a Preface on kind of
what my team does as I mentioned it's at
this intersection of product research uh
customer facing interaction and then
also just actual research within the org
um and we support the technical aspects
of the use cases so helping to design
architectures evals tweak Cloud prompts
to get the best out of our models Etc
and then we also bring whatever we see
back into anthropic and we try to build
some of the best products we can for our
customers so so some examples of
projects we worked on or things that we
published include the building effective
uh research uh paper that uh my
colleague Barry published he's going to
be speaking tomorrow and then as well as
that we launched model context protocol
which is a open source protocol for
language models to interact with data
sources and uh Mah is going to be
leading a workshop on that uh on
Saturday I
believe so anthropic as a whole we try
to effectively support our customers but
where we really start to embed at least
team in particular is um we work closely
with customers that are using clot a lot
and they're facing really Niche
challenges in specific use case domains
and they need support from our team to
try to apply some of the newest kind of
latest and greatest research or get the
most out of the models from a prompting
standpoint Etc and so this approach is
pretty additive we often kick off a a
Sprint once the customer is facing those
tricky challenges um that could be L llm
Ops architectures or evals we help them
to find certain metrics that they deem
to be important when they're evaluating
the model against the use case and then
finally um we help them deploy that kind
of iterative loop the result of that
into an AB test environment um and then
hopefully into production and so a part
of that is the importance of evals and
I'll get onto that in a second um but
I'm G to pass it over first to Joe to
talk about some stuff that we did for
intercom yeah so sort of I think this is
a good segue in what Alex was describing
so for those of you don't who don't know
intercom is an AI customer uh service
platform they have an AI agent called
Finn by many measures it's the best in
the market and it's a pretty competitive
market so they had their product uh out
for I think about a year or so and when
we spoke to them they shared where they
wanted to go where they saw the futures
of like customer support and agents and
based on some of the capabilities of our
model we thought that we could have a
pretty good impact on these metrics and
so what we started with was the applied
AI uh lead with their data science team
and we ran a quick twoe Sprint we took
their hardest prompt for Finn and we
compared it uh against a prompt that we
helped them sort of figure out with uh
with Claude and they saw really good
results after the first two weeks so
much so we went on this sort of Sprint
of about two months where we were
basically um fine-tuning and optim
optimizing all of their uh prompts to
get the best performance out of Claude
at the end of this they're able to look
at all their benchmarks and see that
that anthropic was outperforming the
current llm it's also worth noting that
they do a resolution based pricing model
so there's an incentive for everyone for
the model to be really helpful and help
customers solve problems and not be like
a deflection machine where it's like you
know we've probably all experienced them
before and so at the end of these two
months they decided to move forward with
anthropic they launched it you can read
about it it's called fin 2 and I think
just some of the metrics are really like
mindblowing like can solve up to 86% of
customer support volume 51% out of the
box our support team thought about lots
of different options and they actually
adopted uh Finn as well and they saw
very similar resolution rates but also
making it more human so they I think
with our model we can there's much more
of a human element to it so they could
do like uh adjustment of the tone uh
answer length and then was also really
good at doing policy awareness or like
refund policy for instance so unlocking
some new capabilities and we're thrilled
to be partnering with them as they sort
of I think March forward as a leader in
in this
space yeah on a kind of separate note
one of the things I've seen recently is
uh Claude on Twitter acting as some sort
of therapist for a lot of people and I
always find that an entertaining example
of like its character being expressed
yeah um cool so let's get on to some
best practices and mistakes that we see
in the field uh on the goto Market team
so firstly testing and evaluation I'm
sure this those two words have been
mentioned a lot today and probably
tomorrow too um there's some typical
common common mistakes that we see uh
customers struggling with so the first
one is they bu build a really robust
workflow they spent like a bunch of time
building some architecture out and then
they're like okay now we need to
evaluate it like let's build some evals
that's not really how it should work in
practice because your evals are actually
the thing that directs you towards a
perfect outcome right you can't build a
whole workflow without evals probably
from the GetGo or very shortly after and
so you know sometimes customers as a
result of struggling with data problems
might not be able to design their evals
you could use Claud to clean that up do
data reconciliation um or just you know
trusting The Vibes too much maybe they
run a couple queries they're like hey it
looks good right are they really testing
that on a representative sample though
like do you have enough samples to say
that the thing that you're looking at is
statistically significant and like or
are you going to you know run a 100
things when it actually goes into prod
and then there's going to be like loads
of outliers uh because you didn't
actually predict correctly what the
customer is going to ask of the model
for example so I challenge you to think
about your use cases as this sort of
Laten space right let's take this kind
of chart here on the left hand side of
the slide right as you explore the
latent space with different functions
that you can apply to the model let's
say prompt engineering prompt caching
stuff like that you're you're basically
moving your kind of position in that Len
space around between attractor States
you know and eventually you want to find
an optimized point but you don't really
know where that is right like if you're
changing an instruction you don't know
how the attention mechanism of the trans
forer is going to eventually result in
some different outcome that might not be
performant and so the only way you can
truly know that is empirically and
that's through evaluations and so I
think that's why evaluations are so
important and a lot of people just don't
understand that soon enough in many ways
I actually tell customers evals are your
intellectual intellectual property like
if you want to be competitive in a space
you need to be able to out compete
people by navigating that l l space and
finding the attractor state state faster
than anyone else
um and so part of you know how you do
that is well firstly setting up some
sort of telemetry uh to back test
ideally that architecture set up in
advance but you know you should invest
in it um designing representative text
cases so let say you're working on that
customer support agent eval you know you
might have a kid come on your website
let's say You're Building it for and
might ask some crazy question like how
do I you know kill a zombie in Minecraft
like it totally unrelated to your
product that's you know still probable
and so you should probably include silly
examples like that in your eval set to
make sure that your model is actually
approaching the response in an
appropriate way or rerouting the
question
Etc cool moving on to the next one um
identifying metrics so a lot of the time
you know there's this intelligence cost
latency triangle of tradeoffs that
people are trying to move in between and
most or organizations can optimize for
one or two of those things but it's very
difficult to meet three at least right
now but realistically that balance
should be defined in advance and you
should know that for your specific use
case you're going to make a trade-off
between those things so let's say a
customer support use case again you care
about your customer getting response
within 10 seconds right more than 10
seconds I think there's been research
done on this uh the customer is likely
going to just log off the page and then
they won't get their response and then
they'll probably complain about your
product to their friends right whereas
if you're looking at a financial
research analyst agent you probably
don't care that it works for 10 minutes
to come up with the actual response to
your question because the decision being
made after that is very important it's
an allocation of capital for example and
so the stakes and time sensity
sensitivity of the decision should
really drive your optimization choices
and you know maybe more instruction sets
lead to longer latency but higher
performance Etc the other thing is ux
could be important right so again on
that customer support agent because we
spoke about intercom you could have
different ways of circum V in that 10c
to 15 seconds specifically you could add
like a little thinking box that bounces
around you could send the customer to
another web page in the meantime have
them read something right like there's
loads of ways to distract and kind of
push on those boundaries but you still
need to know what that important
indicator is and you need to optimize
accordingly finally fine tuning so a lot
of people you know I go into these calls
and they're like oh we want to do fine
tuning I'm like oh here we go again um
fine tuning is not a silver bullet so it
comes at a cost and most people aren't
aware of that cost um the cost is
generally you're doing brain surgery on
the model and thus there can be kind of
limitations to its reasoning in other
fields outside of the thing you're fine
tuning tools um so my encouragement is
try other approaches first right most
people they don't even have their eval
set when they're trying to do fine
tuning right they need to have a clear
success criteria in advance and it's
like only if we can't get that in our
specific specific intelligence domain do
we then do fine tuning don't try to boil
the ocean in advance the difference in
fine tuned capabilities and the wide
variance of which you know failure
versus success looks like in fine tuning
land means that you should be able to
justify the cost of fine tuning and the
effort of doing it right getting a team
fine tuning working with us for example
uh you should be able to justify that
difference and so in in terms of best
practices you you know don't want let to
fine tuning slow you down right you
don't want to say oh I'm only going to
convert this language model use case if
we can actually finally fine tune our
model it's like no no pursue it and then
realize that you need to do fine tuning
and then you can just sub in the fine
tuned model and then explore other
methods first and there are loads of
different methods that you know are
anthropic as well as other companies are
working on these days and I just wanted
to like flash up a few of them as we
wrap things up here and so I'm not going
to go through all of these but alongside
just BAS prompt engineering which
granted is very important there are
loads of different features or
architectures that will change the
success of your use case drastically so
for example you might not need to
sacrifice on intelligence of your model
if in order to speed it up by like
removing instructions if you can just
leverage P caching and have a 90%
reduction in cost and a 50% increase in
speed right or contextual retrieval will
drastically improve the performance of
your retrieval retrieval mechanisms and
thus you feed the information to the
model more effectively and thus it has
less of a Time processing all the
instruction set that you've given it so
there are quite a few things that you
can apply here and some of them are even
out of the box like citations and then
there are also architectural decisions
like agentic architectures you know
Barry my colleague who's speaking
tomorrow we'll have a lot to say on that
um but that pretty much does it um thank
you so much for uh for your time we'll
be in the theater level Lounge after
this chat for followup questions um
anything else from you Joe no thank you
so much cool
[Music]